hello everyone if you enjoy Tess and are
a fan of the animated TV series The
Simpsons well you've probably already
seen the episode we're making scarce and
makes an appearance and the entire
episode of Simpsons is dedicated to
chess you hear a wonderful story how
Homer started playing chess how we play
chess with his father how he became
extremely good and why and it's all very
touching and this is one of the games
from this episode it's been a while
since I saw it I don't actually remember
if Homer is playing against his wife or
is he just explaining it the position to
her but I do remember what game it was
as it's the famous trading miniature
Richard ready against Selita Taco Bell
and it's a beautiful game one of the
probably most beautiful miniatures ever
so a red is white and Tata cover is
black
although in the series Homer is white so
we have e for c6 the caro-kann defense
d4 d5 Knight to c3 D captures on e4 and
Knight captures on e4 and Knight to f6
and in this position
Homer plays Queen to d3 and this is a
pretty old mu nobody would play Queen to
d3 nowadays as well simply in Knight
captures on e4 or simply g6 or or any
developing movies okay for black but we
have a e5 here but knock over and okay
ready captures D captures any file and
what Quinta if I would check better to
d2 covering up and black we capture the
pawn so blacks idea is okay I did ways
to move with my queen I did give white
some development but this night is
attacked twice and it's also pinned so
why can't really just castle or attack
my queen with Knight to f3
but that aquifer was wrong and we have
queenside castle hereby ready or by
homer and well okay it's pretty obvious
you can't capture the night with the
Queen because the rope to e2 and rook to
e1 and you know you lose the Queen but
after castles what about what about
knife captures on e4 he thought that if
Knight captures on e4 then rate his idea
was to play rook to e1 just pinning you
know the night the Queen and
everything but after f5 and left three
he thought okay I mean it's better for
white but I can play this with black but
after castles he did capture Knight
captures on e4 and well read his next
move is what makes this game one of the
most beautiful miniatures ever created
you're welcome to pause the video and
try and find and find the solution for
ourselves I will give it a couple of
seconds okay those of you who were able
to find this move without seeing this
game ever before I congratulate you it's
it's a wonderful move and the solution
is Queen to d8 check and the black King
has no options really he does have to
capture the Queen so King captures in
the 8th and out with the beautiful
Bishop to g5 with a double check a
discovered check from the rockin d1 and
the check from the bishop and g5 and the
black King can go to c7 and to e 8 but
it doesn't matter if King to e8 then
simply rook to d8 is checkmate and if
King decides to go to c7 then homer
finishes the game nicely with Bishop to
d8 checkmate so yeah a beautiful game I
you know whenever someone who doesn't
really play chess that often you know
asked me could you show me a nice game
you know you know I tried to get him
interested in chess altogether by
showing him a nice short game like this
so yeah thank you all for watching as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and I'll see you soon